let's just talk about mr alex jones
already we got cnn
reporting i love to use cnn for this
stuff alex jones sues house january 6
committee they say conspiracy theorist
and right-wing provocateur alex jones
says he will not comply with demands the
house select committee investigating
january 6 has made for his testimony in
records according to a new lawsuit he
filed on monday the lawsuit seeks to
block the subpoenas and claims jones
should be protected under the first
amendment he says that he will also
decline to answer questions so as not to
incriminate himself it lands at a moment
when the committee has pushed
aggressively for witnesses to share what
they know about the planning of the
january 6 rallies and they are
intentionally in my opinion that's what
i believe the january 6 committees are
intentionally conflating the rallies
with the people storming the capital
because there were a ton of people who
were just like regular people they're
waving american flags as trump was like
we're gonna go watch peacefully and blah
blah blah and they went home and there
was a lady she was like a psyops officer
or whatever in the army she had nothing
to do with anything at the capitol she
went to the rally gone discharged there
were a bunch of people who have lost
their jobs now apparently the guy from
bob's burgers has been fired one of the
guys because they're like
we think he was there so this is look i
think the january 6 committee is
completely insane i think it's all bunk
bs and i think they're trying to strip
resources away from people who support
trump so that they can't support him as
well moving into 2024. well they have to
include the rallies because there's only
so many chewbacca guys grannies and feds
that they have to go after
that are a part of everything else that
happened that other day but it's also
interesting to note here that jones
actually volunteered to submit documents
and answers in writing for this
particular committee and then the
committee refused to do this they are
also requesting his phone records and as
we know the previous committee members
released private phone records there's
also some accusations about phone
records being doctored after they
garnered them from this january 6
committee so there's a lot of reasons
why a lot of people are saying i'm not
going to be complying with this and this
counter lawsuit is going to be
interesting because is i bet there's
probably going to be discovery on both
sides right
maybe i mean steve bannon tried that you
know he was filing saying he wanted
evidence released on what the government
had on this stuff and then the judge was
like no a lot of work for a misdemeanor
a lot of work for misdemeanors because i
think a lot of people forget that like
these charges that they're coming after
him for you know because i've read a
couple of the criminal complaints
written by the fbi agents and uh yeah
they're misdemeanor charges and it's a
lot of work
you're going after a misdemeanor charge
and just so people know like you know
the feds typically don't do a case
unless it's number one a felony and then
number two it's gonna do substantial
substantial time because the thing is
with the federal court system is you
have ausas right assist united states
attorneys and
i don't want to sound like a jerk but
they're kind of divas they don't take
every case that comes to them they want
they want to be able to they want to win
there's a reason why federal prosecutors
have such a high win rate and the reason
why is because they pick and choose
which cases they want to take if the
case isn't good enough they'll say give
it to the state or whatever else
so for them to take misdemeanors and
push it to this level
is a fairly unorthodox obviously i get
it like you know hey these guys broke
into the capitol it's a great sacked you
know you've dealt with this stuff yeah
when you were working at the uh was it
homeland hsi yeah well well see so with
this type of stuff no not in particular
i investigated more like medicine
cartels and everything but i'm very
aware you know what i mean right it was
in your periphery maybe yeah i mean
when you when you do you know criminal
investigations regardless of the agency
that you work for whether it's you know
dea fbi whatever it is we all go through
the same federal court system we use the
same prosecutors same judges etc and you
get very familiar with what every agency
does as far as like you know what their
investigative authority is and in a lot
of cases you have a lot of overlap you
know like for example atf dea fbi hsi we
all have something called title 21 which
is we can all do drug investigations to
certain extents but you know this is
where the fighting comes in between the
agencies because hey well this is my
target no it's not well i'm tired of 21
designated well i am too blah blah so
you know so you get to be very familiar
with other agencies authorities because
of that very situation where there can
be confliction issues i have a question
there's a lot of circumstantial evidence
that there was a lot of undercover
federal agents involved in january 6th
whether provocateurs or organizers do
you think a lot of those rumors are true
and have you been able to see some of
the circumstantial evidence suggesting
that i mean i wouldn't be surprised you
know um you know
because undercover so like the public
will think like it's undercover but it's
nothing more than an agent in plain
clothes because you know there is no
uniform for 1811's or special agents
like they wear regular clothing it's you
know sometimes they might wear a suit
like you see in the movie sometimes they
wear jeans sometimes they wear street
wear so it wouldn't be improbable for
one to be there you know just because of
the situation for them to be out there
and see what's going on and bam you got
your eyewitnesses right there so you
know if you're like in a real undercover
capacity where you're like dealing with
criminals and everything else like that
and you're actually in an undercover
position then that's different yeah
there's some crazy videos out there of
guys clearly antagonizing clearly saying
we're going to go to the capitol and
then those individuals weren't charged
people calling for violence not being
charged so there's a lot of questions
surrounding how
involved the federal government was and
what extent did they help organize and
execute a lot of this i could see that
as potentially problematic though from a
prosecutor a prosecutorial standpoint
because like if you if you had a a uc
agent running around like antagonizing
the crowd like yeah let's storm the
capital blah blah like that would create
so many issues for the prosecution to
build a strong case because you know
then you can say well they were they
predisposed were they going to do it did
the government actually take an active
role in entrapping them so like i could
see how that could be problematic you
know
from a prosecution standpoint those
videos seem a bit over over the top for
me there's there's one guy and he's like
wearing like a red hoodie and he's like
everybody here's what we're gonna do and
and i think i i agree with you on this
one
they're gonna they're gonna be able to
file that like the the defense is gonna
be able to get the evidence the
prosecution has exactly now it's
possible for discovery right right
they're gonna get everything like the
thing is is that anytime there's a
criminal case built like the the
prosecutor has to hand everything over
to the defense which is considered
discovery and there's actually huge
issues if they don't turn everything
over like they can get disbarred they
can get hit with you know a bunch of
issues so they always turn everything
over even if it's not in their best
interest to do so so if they were to
actually do a case and then they found
out the agents were doing this stuff
undercover and if they antagonize the
crowd i doubt any prosecutor that wants
to win would take that case they'd be
like hell no because they used are very
picky yeah yeah i think it's entirely
possible that these guys were some kind
of agent provocateurs or whatever and
we've seen this at many protests even
even left-wing protests you'll see guys
show up it's very obvious that they'll
start violence and you don't know who
they're with the problem is
is it possible yes
i would say how do you prove it anyway
even if it was the case because it's not
going to be through any conventional
means if it's true so i think the simple
answer is probably just rowdy guys who
are like trying to cause trouble but
those guys weren't charged then there's
clear evidence who they are uh what they
did and and there's videos of them
inciting it and there's videos of them
but why aren't they charged as the big
question and some people say that
wouldn't it it's evident but it's not no
well it's not it's actually really
simple
they go to these guys because they know
who they are because they were vocal and
loud and they say you're going to go to
prison unless you tell us the names of
all the people who are with you and then
that guy says you got it boss and then
all of a sudden he's no longer in the
charging documents all of a sudden he's
no longer in criminal complaints because
he's cooperating and giving everybody up
so that that's what i found really
interesting is that people immediately
assume a lot all the time especially
with the defense happens all they find
the one guy look look you got all these
videos and the feds are trying to figure
out who these guys are do you know this
person do you know this person then you
get a video of a guy who's standing
there in plain view of the camera
yelling over and over again what to do
and they're like okay this is going to
be an easy guy to find he's tall he's
this age he looks like this we know what
he sounds like he knows where he is they
find him and then they say who was with
you
who was talking with you give us your
phone and he says yes and then they say
okay we're not going to charge you
because you're cooperating that's giving
the government the benefit of the doubt
which i wouldn't give them
your case um
we're going to wait until this data and
information
in the court proceedings but for right
now there is a lot of circumstantial
evidence we'll see how it unfolds but
there's still so much that we don't know
even the video footage is being kept
away from the general public that's
which is crazy yep which is absolutely
not for sure it's because misdemeanors
it's because
you watch a lot of this footage and it's
people bumbling around confused half the
time you know there was violence and
there was writing but yeah it's it
i i definitely see both perspectives i'm
just giving you guys like
that perspective where like if you were
to actually do that as a uc it could be
extremely problematic to prosecution and
knowing prosecutors and how they operate
federal prosecutors especially they're
extremely selective on what they take
and yes i mean a lot of cases are built
on the backs of you know people
testifying against each other that's how
the big cases are made like if i was an
investigator and i got a guy and i see
him rallying everybody up well i know
for a fact this guy has some kind of
influence on these guys i'm gonna turn
him here's the important thing
alex jones is on video
multiple videos saying do not do this do
not be violent he's telling everyone not
to go to the capitol they're trying to
trick you he's trying to stop them of
all the people many people who were
there antagonizing alex jones was doing
the opposite
the reason why i think they're going
after him they're going after people who
used to work for the trump
administration they're going after jones
they want to drain as much of their
resources as possible so here's the
thing people need to understand about
getting called
to testify before this committee
they're gonna say we you know we hereby
subpoena you to release all phone
records all this all that all otherwise
you know what you have to do then you've
got to hire a lawyer to do it first the
lawyer's gonna have to go through all
your email and figure out what they what
they're entitled to and what they're not
based on these these demands and it is
gonna get expensive otherwise i suppose
you can be like i don't have the money
you can't do it and then i don't know
what they'll do maybe take all of your
emails maybe try and come after
everything you own say okay then we'll
take everything not like you own but
like all of your private data they would
have to get a search warrant though like
with a subpoena like you don't like
subpoenas are a lot of the times it
depends on what agency does it under
what authority but well it's it's
congress yeah subpoenaing well it's not
just that it's also the federal
government pressing charges on a lot of
the people surrounding january 6th inc
including owen troyer that has an open
case against him and an open
investigation by the federal government
uh against them because allegedly he was
near
the capitol and i think correct me if
i'm wrong i think there's videos of
jones outside saying hey you guys are
being set up stop engaging stop fighting
um i mean that video alone in itself
again love love or hate him there's
video of him saying don't do this let's
be non-violent that that should
exonerate him from a lot of this what
are the other things beating the actual
like case if it's criminal they're going
to need a search it's not criminal
though it's not it's not owen troyer it
is
yeah yeah so this is this is the january
this is congress issuing a subpoena for
information for records
so this means
jones has to file a lawsuit to stop them
from getting access to his records or
whatever because you know it'll happen
they'll get access to his records there
will be nothing in there incriminating
but there will be embarrassing things
that will get leaked to the press of
course taken out of context they'll
manipulate the evidence like they did
with with uh but he's got to be able to
serve his fourth amendment right to some
degree he has a obviously a very strong
reasonable expectation of privacy you
know what i'm saying so that i mean
he's got to be
yeah i really doubt they'd be able to
get access to it i can make it simple
for everybody is uh use
and add encryption and use vpns yeah and
tell them to get a warrant yeah but what
if these are like an example to say hey
you know what here's an example if what
not to do let's use alex jones
i hope not i mean i i think he has the
ability and the resources to get a
lawyer but man
they should not like he has a serious
reasonable expectation of privacy in his
emails phone communication et cetera
like you you because i've cause here's
the thing i've done title three
intercepts like i've done those cases
where a title three intercept is when
you listen to a phone real time right or
to get someone's emails or whatever it
takes an enormous amount of probable
cause to get into that stuff now i'm not
sure you said it's not a criminal case
you know but regardless you're still
going to have an expectation of privacy
and if the government's going to come in
and try to get your information fourth
amendment man and yeah they're going to
need some kind of
serious stuff to be able to get well it
depends on what kind of judge signs off
at on it because if we remember the
edward snowden glenn greenwald days we
found out that judges
blankly just generally signed everything
over allowing federal agencies to spy on
of course the americans
interceptions yeah so that's literally
like you're listening in and you can
hear the phone ring and then like oh
how's it going or can you hear them if
the phone's not being active no you
can't so so here's the thing like and
there's there's different spectrums of
this but title three is when you're
listening to a phone like for a criminal
case right which you're they don't know
your eavesdropping yeah they don't they
don't know but this when i did it you
know most of the time when the
government does it's for drug cases
right what i'm saying so it was a drug
investigation that i did and you were
listening to it now i will tell you guys
and anyone will tell you this an
affidavit to to get probable cause for a
title three intercept you need more
probable cause to listen to someone's
phone than to arrest them wow i'll say
that again yeah you need you need more
probable cause to listen to their phone
to arrest them because the thing is is
you need to establish that the phone is
used for some kind of criminal activity
and to be able to do that you have to
gather evidence to show that that phone
is using criminal activity a lot of the
times it's beyond a threshold of an
arrest sorry have you ever uh
dealt with someone using an encryption
like would you listen to signal phone
calls
well
a better a better question is voip right
yeah so if someone dials a number and
presses go that's what you're typically
hitting right so
i never did
on end-to-end encryptions i always did
it on phones but um well that an encrypt
would just be like i got signal on my
phone yeah like whatsapp or signal or
telephone that's not going through a
phone company you know what i mean so
you'd have to go to facebook or whatever
and be like we want access to this and
to direct to this line you know what i
mean so i'm not aware at this point so i
can't speak on an educated fashion but i
will tell you that when i did them we
did them on phones and you know it's
it's not that hard because a lot of guys
they would just like use regular phones
like cell phones they would use cell
phones yeah they would use burner phones
and they would change the phone number
often but so you got to get access to
these phone companies or is this like
yeah i mean yeah you would you would go
through the phone companies to do it but
you would have to have like an enormous
amount of cost to do it but this is
criminal remember so like when you're
doing like a criminal case it has
different you know sets and procedures
than like let's say a fisa court you
know what i'm saying that's like more
national security related you know
that's you know
classified stuff i didn't deal with that
side ever really and the reason why is
because of pain
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you